this is a long time coming I've been a
Dragonball Z fan for a very long time as
you guys know I love anime and it was
one of the first animes that ever
inspired me to watch other animate and
look at entertainment in a different way
if you guys saw my Toonami retro rewind
video you know how I discovered the show
I'm not going to recycle that here let's
just talk about the show and this is
going to have some spoilers for
Dragonball Z if you've never seen this
show before or know nothing about it and
you would like to see it one day I am
going to talk about plot points in
detail if you don't care or if you've
seen it let's enjoy this
so Dragon Ball Z is obviously very
popular a lot of people in America view
it as that late 90s early 2000 show that
people really enjoyed but it was
actually started in the 80s in Japan
when Akira Toriyama wrote a brilliant
manga series that was eventually
transferred over into anime form and we
actually didn't get it here in America
until much later but for whatever reason
despite the fact that by the time we
started watching this show it was
already over a decade old it still holds
up incredibly well and Dragonball Z is
often parodied for a few specific things
namely a lot of powering up
forever basically never-ending all the
time
screaming poor Sean Chimel and
Christopher sabot I feel for you guys
and it's also specifically known for
quite a bit of standoffs
and of course every character getting
their ass kicked against some super
villain waiting for Goku to show up I'm
aware of all the Dragonball cliches and
I simply don't care
every show that's successful that's
long-running has a formula of some kind
right now I'm watching Buffy the Vampire
Slayer for the first time I've never
seen it that show has a formula and it's
successful Buffy will fight a few
vampires in the first few minutes then
there'll be some comedy between Xander
and Willow and Giles and then eventually
there'll be a big showdown at the end
all major shows that are successful
follow a similar formula one of my
favorite shows of all time the x-files
generally opens with Mulder and Scully
looking at a slideshow presentation of
some kind some investigation they're
going to go to Mulder says some funny
things Scully says some skeptical things
and then they go out on their
investigation and right before the
serious paranormal stuff happens Scully
for some reason disappears and Mulder's
the only one who sees it and Dragon Ball
Z is also very similar in that way we
have sagas in which goku is trying to
train to become stronger to eventually
surmount some villain and in between
other people are going to try to fight
this villain as well until goku finally
shows up and hopefully does something
and that's Dragonball Z and a whole what
really makes any TV show great the story
and the characters if the plotting is
fresh and exciting and you actually care
about the people involved with it
then you can watch them do just about
anything except maybe shrink down to
small size and fight monsters inside of
majin buu stomach yeah that's why I draw
the line
also if you had seen Dragonball to show
that preceded Dragon Ball Z for some
time then there's some investment built
up and these characters already
but despite DBZ following a successful
but simple formula it actually did take
a lot of risks with its characters in
the first few episodes of the show
Goku dies I mean he's like the main
character of the show and he's dead
within the first few episodes that's
ballsy get it
ballsy ha ha
I'm sorry for me personally the show's
best characters were usually the
villains that had a change of heart
along the way like piccolo or Vegeta
there's a lot of depth and emotional
background to both of these characters
piccolo always having a confrontation
with Goku and then eventually learning
how to be a different person
through training Gohan while Goku was
dead and that emotional connection
between piccolo and Gohan has always
been one of my favorite aspects of the
entire show because you see a character
that starts off as essentially a demon
and eventually learns to find the
humanity inside of him and in regards to
Vegeta he's my favorite character in
this entire show it's really hard to
pick one because I love Goku I love
Gohan I loved TN I love Crillon I love
piccolo I love trunks there's so many
amazing characters but Vegeta for me is
the most interesting and emotionally
complex and he also has one of the best
scenes in the entire show that in which
he reveals his tortured past at the
hands of the evil Frieza
we weren't so hard we did everything he
asked us and more he took me for my
father when I was just a little boy he
made me do whatever they wanted and said
he would kill my father if I didn't I
did everything as when he killed him
anyway along with everyone else my
personal favorite saga in all of DBZ is
the frieza saga it's the culmination of
Goku zark ascending as a Super Saiyan
it's the culmination of the arc of the
Saiyans one of their own eventually
taking on Frieza the tyrant of their
entire race and winning it feels as if
the entire show has been building to
this saga now some have said that
accurate or Yama should have just
stopped after the freezer saga that was
it there was no more fun to be had now I
can understand why you might think that
because as I just said it feels as if
both of the major arcs the Saiyans and
Goku have now been fulfilled and where
else do you go from this well there's
one specific arc left for a character
that has been explored throughout the
entirety of the show up into that point
and that is go han the show has a lot of
hints that Gohan is stronger than
everyone else around him and since these
two characters are what spawned Gohan
that doesn't surprise me at all so the
show was also building to this as well
we see little Gohan take on Raddatz
during Piccolo's training with Gohan we
got more glimpses of that inner power
when Gohan was trying to fight Frieza
even in his final form he got some hits
in so that is saying that Gohan has got
some hidden and we don't really get
to see that come to fruition until the
brilliant cell saga and we finally get
to see Gohan really transform into what
he's supposed to be this amazing badass
character who's stronger than everyone
else around him even his father and so
we got to see that arc fulfilled as well
so yes I do think Dragon Ball should
have continued after the frieza saga
because if it didn't we also wouldn't
have gotten the really fun Android saga
and one of my other favorite characters
trunks and Gohan's final fight with cell
is so unbelievably awesome there are so
many amazing moments I get chills just
thinking about it which brings me to the
nerdy stuff not only does Dragonball Z
have good characters and an entertaining
story it's freaking epic
[Music]
my humble opinion Dragon Ball Z is the
best action anime ever made hands down I
really don't think there's much
competition quite a bit of an amazing in
the 80s and early 90s when this show was
made did a technique of freeze framing
battles they would have characters
rushed towards each other and then you
would get these slow-moving panning
freeze frame moments you wouldn't get
fully animated action sequences like
Dragon Ball Z introduced where you could
see their bodies moving performing
kung-fu and it was fully completely
realized through animation there were no
cheap techniques there was no half-assed
animation Dragon Ball Z took all of that
very seriously and it made it extremely
fun to watch even way after the show had
already debuted in Japan here in America
it felt new and fresh in the early 2000s
when it had been old in Japan already so
after the cell saga ended Akira Toriyama
was like alright I'm done yeah we're
finished fans wanted more so we got the
Majin Buu saga and this is where things
get a little iffy for Dragon Ball Z for
myself personally I like the first half
of the boost stuff the great saying man
stuff Gohan meeting Vidal and Goku and
Vegeta fighting 1 Vegeta becomes Majin
Vegeta I like all of that stuff the
beginning of majin buu even is okay when
Vegeta eventually sacrifices himself but
where Dragon Ball Z really loses steam
for me is when Buu starts changing into
dozens of different forms and after that
it just becomes so messy and it just
feels like hey let's just have go tanks
appear and fight him let's have super
mystic Gohan up here and fight him hey
let's have Goku come back and fight him
with Vegeta and it's just like okay
there are great little morsels of
sequences throughout the Majin Buu saga
towards the last half like Vegeta
finally acknowledging that Goku is the
best when when that seemed that that
scene is just perhaps it is my anger
that's made me blind to the truth for so
I see it now this dais made it all too
clear you're better than me Kakarot you
are the best it's one of those things
where you're like I just watched so many
hours of this show and seeing this
happen it's just it's like this giant
breath of fresh air is just emitted but
boo turning everyone into chocolate and
eating Goku and Vegeta and them fighting
monsters inside his belly it just it
really jumps the shark and it goes way
overboard at that point the reason I
like the first half of the Buu saga is
because there is a reason to watch we
got to see Gohan meet his Ark and ascend
to Super Saiyan 2 and everything but
then we get to see him older he's
meeting Vidal he's trying to figure out
a way to use his powers for people's
good as being the great se man but at
the same time there was a little bit
more to learn about him also the last
major arc that was still left over from
the rest of the sagas was Vegeta still
having a grudge against Goku so we got
to see that arc fulfilled when they had
one last battle but after that the show
really doesn't have anywhere else to go
and you can feel it because the last
remaining episodes are a bit of a drag I
love Dragon Ball Z it's one of my
favorite shows of all time but I have no
problem admitting that the last half of
the Buu saga kind of sucks guys those
are my thoughts on DBZ it's one of my
favorite animes of all time I did this
review because Dragon Ball super is
about to premiere on Toonami on January
7th and I can't wait to start watching
it I've been waiting because I prefer
the dub I like my Goku voiced by a man
[Music]
and now is the perfect time to finally
sit down and talk about this incredibly
inspirational anime that I have loved
for a very long time I'm gonna give
Dragon Ball Z and a oh look at all you
pee on Zout there behind your worthless
computer screens but wait what is this
you're not stuck mine eyes yet oh you've
got to be kidding me
I am the Prince of all Saiyans and I
command you to get stuck mine eyes
[Applause]
[Music]
you